my advisor also is very much determined
to come here to give the talk but
unfortunately she have to bail because
of some family situation but she wanted
me to send her greetings to the people
in the room regardless so here I am and
where I'm going to talk about our
workout the one over K convergence of
asynchronous tis true the ad mm method
so yesterday I think the park was using
a dmm to softer to predict clicks to
rating linkedin data set and this talk
we're going to work with the ADM method
itself and will be more on the the
theory side so throughout the talk the
keywords I want to keep on you to keep
your mind is the ones in blue rate 1
over K asynchronous and distribute it
okay so first let's see why these
tributing methods are interesting but I
guess I don't have to multi very much
for audience in this room we are no
today there's a explosion in data size
and that's impossible to process
everything ago just one note by itself
therefore we are working with large
scale networks with agents that has
local information and or maybe
heterogeneous preferences and here are
some motivating examples in
communication networks control networks
sensor network and even the grid so for
the rest of the talk we're going to
focus on this particular formulation
here in red and it's given by minimize
some of fi of X so we're going to be
given a network of n agents so n nodes
connected here labeled 1 through n and
the function itself is local so each of
fi is only know to that note I however
this a decision variable X viewed as a
vector in RN that's common to everyone
like other nodes and the objective here
is to collectively minimize the sum of
the individual objectives the assumption
we're going to have here is that each of
the FI is going to be complex and not
here it's just convex we're not going to
assume any smoothness so no Lipschitz
creating
or even strongly convex assumption on
that and just to be more formal what we
mean by distributing is here is that
we're going to keep each of the f is
local and the only communication allow
these two is to exchange information
with your nearest neighbor but not the
entire f of I so okay let's see that's a
lot of math up there why is this
particular formulation interest in or
even relevant for for the people here
okay let's take a look at the least
square problem to spread up butter of
machine learning and so let's see the
graph here we're collecting a bunch of
data and it looks like we can fit a
certain reek polynomial and not task of
course to learn the coefficients of the
polynomial here so let's say somehow we
have a lot of data and they won't fit on
the same processor for instance let's
say we have the data are collected
through three different processors and
denoted by these are color-coded here
and collectively we're trying to
minimize the sum of loss functions so
each chapter is going to figure out a
coefficient and they're going to talk to
their neighbor and then eventually they
will agree on one set of coefficient
that minimize the sum of the last
functions okay and of course imagine
this scales up to and of course more
than three I mean if it's three you can
probably deal with it on your laptop
itself okay and then more generally
other than the least square a lot of
machine learning problems for full falls
into this formulation here in red where
we are minimize the sum of loss
functions and maybe plus a penalty here
which is the panel Isis for the
complexity of the model for instance la
so here we have the square norm plus a
l1 non-regular regularization term here
okay and one one thing we can do here is
to view this as a sum of N individual
functions so n minus one comes from the
first loss component and the last one fi
comes from the penalty okay so all of
these
all of these are machine learning tasks
falls into the previous formulation we
have okay so all right that's an
interesting problem so how do we solve
it well people have been looking at this
problems through the lens of distributed
optimization and the most relevant ones
are the ones that change it into the
formulation here in red so remember we
have the f ice that's local but then
they are share the common X which is the
decision variable across our notes right
so the way to distribute that is to
introduce the local copy at each of the
note and of course we're going to assume
the the nodes are connected through a
connected graph so as long as we force
the decision variable to be equal across
the edges if the graph is connected we
in the end recover the original problem
so this is a formulation that's the
graph representation of that and people
have developed distributed methods based
on gradient or subgradient methods and
it's very nice in the sense that the
implementation is very simple you take a
gradient step at every iteration and you
mix with your neighbors you can average
that to maintain the same decision
variable exiting to guarantee you
converge to the same X in the end the
downside though is static the rate of
convergence is kind of slow the known
radius 1 over square root of K where K
is a number of iterations and it's done
by the work is done by some people in
the room here so and so it's ok so we
have a way of solving it but it's a
little slow all right then we learned
recently that a dmm performs very well
alternating Direction message
multipliers so can we do something with
a DMM to solve this large-scale
distributed problem and so first first
off let's see how fast could we possibly
help for 480mm
so the known rate for general convex
problem is 1 over K establishing 22
years ago and under more strict
assumptions a restrictive assumptions
such as the gradient lip ship being
Lipschitz or strong convexity we can
improve the rate to linear rate but the
recall our motivation was the lasso
formulation which has a l1 norm regular
rides and we don't want to assume
anything that's up here so the best we
could hope for is order 1 over K and the
problem with the this paper here or the
existing method on a DMM rather is that
they require synchronous implementation
okay so we have a large scale system and
the idea is we both wanted to be
distributed and asynchronous meaning we
don't want some central coordinating
agent saying okay now everyone update ok
nevermind everyone wait again and then
total that something happens everyone
finishes and then the other updates so
we want to get rid of that central
coordinating agent ok so in this talk
I'm going to show or we're going to
establish together a asynchronous
distributed 80mm and we can show that it
converges with rich one over K which is
the best we could hope for ok so first
let's recap a little bit what exactly do
I mean by admn ok so here's the problem
that standard 80mm stop seeing red we're
going to minimize the sum of FY plus f
of X plus G of Y so to decision
variables x and y coupled through a
linear constraint here and we're going
to form what called augmented lagrangian
function so first we are selling a P
which is a dual variable to this linear
constraint and then the augmented
lagrangian is formed by the first return
which is the lagrangian plus a quadratic
penalty on the feasibility violation
here and once we have the augmented
lagrangian oh i should say the beta here
is the penalty parameter and also serves
as a step size later on so once we have
the augmented lagrangian what we're
going to do is we first fix why then
minimize X and then given the X X 1 X at
k plus 1 we
minimize why and then we take a dual
descent direction the dual gradient
direction so again it's you first fit
first optimize X then Y so alternating
Direction that's the fat part of the
name and then we change the multiplier
so alternating Direction method of
multiplier the name okay and so okay one
thing i should say is that later on when
we when we talk about the other rate of
convergence we count how many times this
entire loop is going to take so we're
not counting the work inside each of
this minimization okay and so luckily
for some problems that we are interested
in this minimization can be done pretty
efficiently given that we fix the other
parameter or the other variable here and
if you're interested you can check out
the survey book written by Stephen
Boyd's group on that okay so now let's
go back to our problem which is this one
here you read and we're going to adopt
the same reformulation that the the
gradient group people developed and
let's say we only have two agents okay
just two notes x1 or node well no.2 with
x1 and x2 and the constraint here is x 1
equal to x2 okay so this is very nice
that it's a special case of the previous
admn we introduced so we can just
blindly apply the ML on this method and
it let's take a look at what the idiom
is going to do ok this is the augmented
lagrangian we look at it we're
minimizing with respect to x one so we
can drop some constant terms which
doesn't involve X 1 and it becomes
shorter and then once we have the X 1 k
plus 1 we're going to minimize with
respect to X 2 and another then we drop
the constant terms and lastly we're
going to take the great other duels
update a dual variable here okay so
that's all nice but what happens if we
have more than two nodes in the network
imagine we naively apply the previous
message to the graph and imagine we have
a past graph that means it we would have
to get node one first update no.2 then
note 3 then note 4 so that would take n
iterations to loop through everything
and that is slow so your algorithm each
the iterate the the complexity per
iteration would scale with the number of
nodes so though we can show that method
does conversion has way 1 over K but
it's a little bit slow so we are now
motivated to look into some way of some
way to make the iteration complexity
like per iteration more efficient so
what are we going to do we're going to
borrow this trick from boticca static
clicks book from 89 that we introduced
this decision variable Z here what it
does is it decouples the X from each
other so now after this D transformation
every X is only going to coupled with
the Z variable instead of all the other
exits which you have to wait ok and here
is what it looks like it's very
simple-looking transformation so at this
X i equal XJ we're going to introduce to
Z variables denoted by ze is eega and
we're going to require X i equal to ze I
minus XJ equal zej and of course the sum
of these equal to zero I mean clearly
these two formulations are equivalent ok
but the nice thing is now that we have
the decision variables X and Z's and
they are decoupled ok so this is our new
formulation and we're going to write the
constraint compactly as DX equal to Z
where D has the plus 1 and minus ones
there ok and ok so so far been talking
about the distributive part and as I
promise there will be a synchronous
aspect of the algorithm so how does that
come in play well we're going to assume
each of the edge is equipped with a
Poisson clock in the sense that the edge
will wake up and both of the nodes will
become active at that iteration so here
we're going to pick the constraint so
we're going to activate
each of the constraint instead of each
of the note that is because a DMM is
really a dual kind of message so
everything should be viewed in the
length of the constraint domain okay and
so when the constraint becomes active we
would call the notes so here the let's
say this age 23 becomes active so the
note 2 and 0 3 becomes active and we
denote by this pei and pj for the dual
variables associated with these two
constraints separately and here's what
the algorithm looks like that's exactly
what you would expect given the previous
admn so we would minimize the x given a
disease at the previous iteration and
then minimize Z and then update the P
it's a dual variable okay so let's take
a look at how this implement this
updates can be implemented the ones in
red only require local information so
those are no problem the only problem is
this d part which has this coupling
constraint zei and the ej oh i should
mention that each of the zei and PIR
control our own updated by the note I
and everything that has a J's updated by
the j-1 so with that in mind we can see
all these red ones can be dying a local
fashion whereas this the update has a
coupling effect here so the nice thing
here then is if we take a closer look at
the Z it's nothing more than a quadratic
programming with the linear constraint
which has an explicit solution so we
derive the the close close form solution
for the Z and it turns out to be very
simple it's just the average of the duel
and the difference of the primal ok so
that's probably too much much let's see
how it can be actually implemented and
what is a communication here required ok
so let's say again this age 23 becomes
active all right now first we need to
update the axis and what it needs is a
piece and z's from previous iteration at
that node so here's no communication
did the purple ones are the inflammation
that is already available whereas the
red ones are the ones being updated here
okay so first using the piece and these
we can get the X updated and then we
look at the Z update what we need here
is x ik plus 1 and x JK + 1 so here is
the information exchange we're going to
send the newly updated decision
variables across and keep in mind that
this is the same as the dimension of the
problem the decision of the parameters
that you try to learn so it's not like
we're exchanging data over but the
actual parameters were learning ok and
then given the updated axis and also the
piece from previous time we can compute
the v's and note that because the visa
updated from previous times through this
step c so p 2 3 and 3 2 is as pei and
pjs are going to be equal to each other
so we can simplify this the update into
a more locally computable ones here and
then once we computers of V which is
like an intermediate step you can
compute the Z using our local
information again okay and then the dual
variable P here can be updated using the
intermediate variable V we just obtained
and turns out this has more general
applications than what we had so so far
we be talking about the problem some of
a Phi of X I subject to X i equal XJ and
turns out this asynchronous distributed
a dmm can be applied to more general
constraining of the form and DX plus HC
equal to 0 okay all right so now let's
look at the method and one thing you
might be wondering is what happened to
the probability because the first thing
that we tried is we scaled this ffq or f
eyes based on how frequent the update
you would expect that the ones update
more often to kind of scale downwards so
that it doesn't mess up the eventual
solution
in the end right but see that is not
true we tried it it still converges but
to the wrong value and the reason being
admn really should be viewed in a duo
space so the primal should just blindly
respond to the duel at these two to the
dual variables that is given but then so
how do we deal with the different
frequency in a dual space the short
answer is we don't and give me a 20
minutes I'll tell you why in the the
convergence results okay so here's the
our convergence results the assumption
we have here is that each of the
constraint will wake up infinitely often
that something very reasonable if you
don't even update then it's pretty
hopeless to converge to the right value
okay and under that infinitely often
assumption we can show both primal and
dual converges to the optimal solution
with probability 1 so almost sure
convergence and the the sketch of the
proof is given as follows so we're going
to compare our asynchronous update to
the fully what we call full information
update meaning everyone going to update
at the same time so and turns out the
asynchronous update and the full
information update value agree on the
active components where as a passive
compare now the null active components
keep their value from previous iteration
so the trick here to prove it for the
synchronous case is to use this Lyapunov
function here up in red and the so we
need to map the synchronous we have no
function somehow into the asynchronous
domain and the way to do that is to
introduce a new norm that is that is
weighted by the different probability
the probability of how often each of the
constraint become active so this is the
answer to how do we account for
different frequencies update in the duo
space so we're not going to look at our
uniform kind of convergence but I waited
norm so the more frequent it the
different frequencies here would map to
fast each of the component converges ok
and then so that was convergence with
probability 1 and what about the rates
that was the other blue key word that we
highlighted in the first page so under
further assumption of the consider the
constraints that being compact which we
recently relaxed we can also show that
the objective function converges with 3
1 over K expectation and similar results
hold for the feasibility violation or
the constraint violation here where the
so alpha here is a scalar that depends
on the initial conditions ok all right
so this is pretty much the best we can
hope for because we know that the
synchronous ID mmm has some best known
rate of 1 over K and here in the
asynchronous case we get 1 over K
expectation so so we're pretty happy
with the result and then we started to
run some simulations so disclaimer here
is that I don't have access to a big
data or a big machine to run things so
they're all going to be a very small
scale ok so the the algorithms odors of
the benchmark here is another
asynchronous method so guess I skip this
part there on that many asynchronous
message that it has known either
convergence or rate of convergence
guarantees so the only one that we know
is by this UIUC group here that develops
asynchronous based on the gradient steps
of the use of some kind of gossip
protocol protocol to implement the
gradient based algorithm and then
there's another group in France that
recently developed a synchronous 80mm
method but they don't have rate of
convergence so basically our work is the
first a synchronous type of method that
has rate of convergence guarantee ok so
the benchmark we used here is the
asynchronous gossip algorithm which has
convergence but not rate of convergence
guarantee and we're going to play with
this 5 no 2 tiny little graph here and
so what we plotted here is the evolution
of the each of the exes so if you see
the lines all converge to the same point
that means the valley 0 converge to the
optimum so to reach the five-percent
neighborhood of optimal solution
asynchronous a dmm took 80 iterations
and gossip took a synchronous gossip
took 250 the region's because this is
expected because asynchronous gossip is
based on the gradient type of method
which has real one over square root of K
whereas a DMM has one over K okay and
then we tried a line graph which is a
little bit more dramatic the difference
it's 10 folds difference asynchronous a
DMM took 70 where's the gossip one took
some 100 iterations so then we wonder
what happens to complete graph so again
a five note graph we run the ad mmm and
gossip so here to reach five percent
neighborhood precision an emm took 140
iterations whereas asynchronous gossip
took 380 iteration so the difference
becomes very different depends on the
graph topology that's something we're
studying under right now to understand
how network topology affects the
performance of the algorithms okay and
just to throw in one more examples here
we also try to around the asynchronous
80mm on the image denoising application
so here's the original camera cameraman
figure and then we added some wine noise
to it and to run the district to respect
the distributed nature we split the
graph just in the middle to two
different processors and also so the
objective here is to minimize the sum of
differences recovering the original with
respect to the measured graph and also
the total variation difference so the
penalty in the end we have three
processors these two other this half and
this half where is this third figure
panel Isis for the overall complexity
okay and turns out that admn does
perform pretty well with these three
split we were able to recover this
figure which looks pretty much the same
as the one we started with after 87
integrations 35 seconds on my laptop so
if I had access to bigger machines of
bigger data as we probably would have
better results to show you but that's
pretty much all we have in terms of
simulations okay so to conclude we
developed a synchronous distributed 80mm
method that has a personal rate of 1
over k and so we also have simulation
results that says it's a little bit
better than the gradient based method
but again okay let me emphasize again
the iteration count here is the outer
loop so we're not accounting for the
inside each of the argument operations
but for the examples given we are used
quadratic once and it what the argument
was actually pretty easy to obtain so
for more complicated problems we might
have to think clicking carefully either
if there is an efficient solver for each
of the inner loop then we're good if not
maybe we shouldn't deal with the a DMM
type of method okay so and some future
ongoing work is that we're looking at
dynamically changing topology and how
the graph topology affects the
performance of the algorithm and with
that I'll conclude and be happy to take
any questions thanks